>> Laura: WELCOME BACK.
HERE WITH US NOW IS A MAN WHO
SURVIVED THE SHOOTING FROM THE
FRONT ROW OF THE VIP SECTION OF
THAT FATEFUL LAS VEGAS CONCERT
BACK IN OCTOBER.
BRIAN CLAYPOOL JOINS US NOW.
ALSO AN ATTORNEY, ASSISTING
DOZENS OF SURVIVORORS AND
VICTIMS’ FAMILIES.
BRIAN, TO BE BACK HERE IN
LAS VEGAS, SECOND TIME I’VE BEEN
HERE SINCE THE SHOOTING, I
THOUGHT BY THIS TIME I WOULD
HAVE MORE ANSWERS TO REPORT ON.
BUT EVERY TIME WE GET A NEW
PIECE OF INFORMATION IT RAISES
ANOTHER QUESTION.
WHAT IS THE BURNING QUESTION IN
YOUR MIND THAT WE HEAR THAT
THERE MAY BE CHARGES, MORE
CHARGES IN THIS CASE?
>> WELL, LAURA, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME.
AND TO LET YOU KNOW, THIS IS MY
FIRST DAY BACK IN LAS VEGAS
SINCE BEING A SURVIVOR OF THE
SHOOTING.
I HAD A MEETING ON THE VEGAS
SHOOTING CASE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, WHEN I GOT
OFF THE PLANE I WAS TALKING
TOWARD THE XILT OF THE AIRPORT
AND I SAW THE MANDALAY BAY OUTTS
WINDOW.
I HAD TWO FEELINGS THAT CAME TO
ME.
ANXIETY, AND THEN THE SECOND
FEELING WAS ANGER.
I SPEAK FOR ALL OF THOSE
SURVIVORS OUT THERE AND ALL
THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO LOST
LOVED ONES IN THE SHOOTING.
HERE’S WHAT WE WANT TO KNOW.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHY THE HAS
VEGAS METROPOLITAN POLICE
DEPARTMENT, THE FBI, IN CONCERT
WITH THE MGM AND MANDALAY BAY
ARE SCRIPTING A NARRATIVE THAT
THIS IS JUST A LONE WOLF
SHOOTING.
THAT THIS IS JUST SOME
64-YEAR-OLD OR HOWEVER OLD THIS
DUDE WAS, PADDOCK DESHGS PRESSED
GUY THAT WANTED TO DO A MASS
SHOOTING.
WE KNOW THAT’S LIKELY NOT TO BE
THE CASE.
BUT YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
EARLIER.
GREED IN THIS SHOOTING, ECLIPSES
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND WE WANT ANSWERS.
WHY THE MGM AND MANDALAY BAY DID
NOT BETTER PREPARE FOR THIS MASS
SHOOTING.
REMEMBER, YOU TALK ABOUT THIS
BEFORE, IN MAY OF THIS YEAR, OF
LAST YEAR, THERE WAS A CREDIBLE
REPORT OF A POTENTIAL ISIS
ATTACK IN VEGAS.
SO THIS WAS NO, YOU KNOW, NO
FICTIONAL EVENT THAT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
I KNOW WE’RE GOING TO FIND OUT
IN DISCOVERY IN THIS CASE THAT
THE METROPOLITAN P.D. AND
SHERIFF LOMBARDO MET WITH THE
CASINOS TO MAKE SURE THEY HAD
SOME KIND OF PLANS IN PLACE TO
PREVENT AS NG MASS SHOOTING.
MESSAGED ME WHO WAS THERE THAT
NIGHT.
HE SAID, AND YOU COULD CONFIRM
THIS, WHEN THEY ALLOWED PEOPLE
TO LEAVE THE VICINITY THE ONES
THAT DIDN’T ALREADY GET OUT,
THEY DIDN’T CHECK ANYONE WHO WAS
LEAVING.
THE POLICE ACTUALLY, THERE WAS
NO CHECK -- SOMETIMES PEOPLE
BLEND IN WITH THE CROWD.
OBVIOUSLY THIS GUY WAS ON THE
MULTIPLE FLOORS UP.
EVEN THAT WAS ODD HERE.
WE’RE ALMOST OUT OF TIME, FINAL
THOUGHTS FROM YOU.
>> YEAH, LAURA, LET ME JUST TELL
YOU THIS, I WAS IN THE MANDALAY
BAY.
I STAYED THERE, I WAS ON THE
26th FLOOR.
LET ME TELL YOU HOW BAD THE
SECURITY WAS.
THE DAY AFTER THE SHOOTING, I
FINALLY WENT TO TRY TO GET BACK
IN MY ROOM.
THERE WAS FINALLY A SECURITY
GUARD THERE.
HE DIDN’T EVEN ASK ME FOR ANY
I.D.
I WENT RIGHT UP TO MY MANY.